to face conversation in more than a year
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
and Russian foreign minister zegi lavrov
have had an unexpected meeting on the
sidelines of the G20 meeting in New
Delhi the two spoke for less than 10
minutes while divisions over the war in
Ukraine have dominated the G20 the
Indian foreign minister has confirmed
there'll be no joint statement from the
meeting saying they can't reach a
consensus Russia and China were the only
two countries to refuse to support a
demand for Moscow to withdraw from
Ukrainian territory
joins us now from the summit venue in
New Delhi and bhavni so they have
confirmed no joint communique and the
impasse is obviously very embarrassing
for the host nation who really wanted to
shine here
Minister's meeting of G20 nations in New
Delhi has ended on a tense and divisive
note there is no joint declaration or
joint statement and this was expected
given what happened last week at the G20
meet of Finance ministers and it is
because of opposing views held by
participating Nations on the ongoing war
in Ukraine that is the dominant theme of
g20's meeting today and has been uh even
last week at the finance Minister's
meeting now the other big news is that
the U.S and Russia met for the uh for
the first time the highest level meeting
since the War Began this was not
scheduled but Secretary of State Anthony
blinken and Russian foreign minister
Sergey lavrov met for about 10 minutes
tops in this uh the U.S reiterated its
unwavering support for Ukraine blinken
also urged lavrov to reverse the
suspension of the new start nuclear arms
treaty that Russia suspended recently
now Sergey lavrov held a press
conference in which he blamed Western
Nations for making quote emotional
statements and derailing the G20 agenda
lavrov also came in support of China
China now was criticized by the United
States and by Germany today for
supplying weapons to Russia what sort of
tensions have there been in terms of the
way both Russia and the us at this
Summit have tried to make other G20
Nations pick a side
when Nations have been reiterating their
positions and we have seen that divide
between you know countries like Germany
like the United Kingdom like the
European Union Block sort of double down
on Russia calling it an aggressor while
you know countries like China have been
pushing uh China has been pushing its 12
point peace plan but the tensions over
here have also put the spotlight on
India's diplomatic heft and its ability
to sort of keep walking that diplomatic
tightrope countries like India have been
importing oil from Russia even though
there are sanctions India also has close
ties with the United States now the
other thing to note is that the agenda
for India has been to really focus on
issues of the global South New Delhi has
viewed this G20 presidency as a golden
opportunity to project itself as the
voice of the global South and uh you
know prime minister Andrew Modi in
today's statement also urged Nations to
find common ground on issues like
inflation issues like food security and
climate change now India's foreign
minister did say that there was some
sort of Meeting of Minds on those issues
but because of uh you know differences
over the war in Ukraine there was no
joint statement the uh the concern now
is in the question rather now is can
India pull off what Indonesia did last
year that is end its G20 presidency
order sort of consensus you know last
year there was that Bali declaration and
it does at this point seem to be a tall
order to achieve that when world leaders
meet for the final Summit in September
but if that does happen it will be a big
goal uh for uh prime minister Narendra
Modi both internationally as well as
domestically
above the middle of their forest in New
Delhi thank you
now of the 19 countries and the European
Union that make up the G20 15 voted in
favor of an immediate end to the war in
Ukraine at the U.N General Assembly
Russia opposed the motion China India
and South Africa abstained now China and
Russia have no formal military Alliance
but they have strong ties based around
arms sales and joint exercises
economically Russia is increasingly
reliant on China while India's military
is heavily dependent on Russian tanks
fighter jets and other equipment India
is the world's third largest consumer of
oil and buys it from Russia South Africa
has deepened its military ties with
Russia the two Nations held joint Naval
exercises on the anniversary of the
invasion South Africa described Russia
as its friend trade between the
countries in 2021 totaled about a
billion dollars
well let's bring in Haman Bashar Al
Jazeera senior political analyst and it
does seem marwin that the foreign
ministers from the U.S and Russia have
met and spoke and it seems for
appearance sake accidentally on purpose
yes absolutely
not exactly spontaneous as it were
but it really begs the question soil why
leaked to the press as to what secretary
blinken told foreign minister lavrov
instead of actually saying it in the
open platform in the conference
I mean it sounds to me like a great
Point talking point
for the Secretary of State
to tell the Russian foreign minister why
don't you people come back to New Start
and let's talk about the nuclear
proliferation and let's start about
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons and
he could have talked about the danger
the escalation
of not having nuclear agreements between
the two World superpowers and what that
means for nuclear proliferation
worldwide since we are talking about
other countries thinking about or
enriching uranium or becoming nuclear
States like Japan Iran and others
so it really begs the question why go on
the sideline and talk about that instead
of mentioning it in the whole because
this meeting is meant exactly for
something like that instead what you've
seen is meeting after meeting after
meeting whether it's the U.N security
Council or the G20 becoming a forum for
diatribes and bickering
not a place where there is constructive
engagement do you think this there was a
this issue of perhaps not wanting to try
and embarrass the house India allowing
them to shine as hosts of the G20 and so
therefore this conversation was taken to
one side because India themselves have
had a very difficult line to tread in in
setting up this whole conference with
what's gone on in Ukraine over the past
12 months and one gets a sense really
that we're back to the 1970s and 80s the
sort of sort of semi-cold War whose side
you're on you're with us so you're not
going on absolutely look uh as our
correspondent mentioned uh there was no
mention that I know of of China's 12
points which already been turned down by
NATO's Secretary General the Americans
the Europeans are exactly playing the
game they're not even building on those
12 points that are really just
guidelines to you know stop the war and
let's discuss how Russia could
eventually you know come to a peace
agreement with Ukraine and clearly
India's efforts are not appreciated as
well because the West especially but
also Russia they want allies they want
with us or against us kind of deal but
that's notably the United States and
hence it's undermining whatever efforts
coming from the Turks from the Indians
from the Chinese because it simply wants
unconditional Russian withdrawal from
Ukraine and into the war that way and
they're not accepting any from the
diplomacy and in the process and I must
emphasize that because I just saw your
list of
this hybrid world that we live in with
Russia China South Africa Brazil and so
on so forth taking this kind of a
vague ambiguous positions you know
wanting to play Both Sides to want to
hedge their their positions but what is
happening in the process so hell because
you talked about military agreements
between these countries
what we've seen is that there's an
increase in military spending in the
world like never before in the history
of humanity this year in fact last year
we jumped to two point
two trillion dollars 2.2 trillion
dollars of military spending huge Rises
of military spending not only by the
United States and Russia but also by
China Japan
and other parties within Europe and
outside Europe Germany and Japan are
arming right so there is an arms race
being fueled by this bickering that is
going on but isn't there also another
sort of observation here that countries
like India
um Brazil South Africa emerging markets
were part of the brics
organization with
China and Russia are are not uh don't
need to actually say whose side they're
on because the world has changed in 30
years since the the fall of uh or the
breakup of the former Soviet Union the
Cold War the reduction generally in
nuclear weaponry different alliances
have been made and not not necessarily
uh stuck in stone they're very movable
absolutely that's what I meant by
um there's a hybrid world that we live
in it's neither gas or electric right I
mean it's both it's not that the United
States States or Russia it's both and
it's not just both of them it's also
China and it's also Indian and so
countries and governments and regimes
even totalitarian regimes are finding it
easier now to to pick and choose yeah
you know a recent meeting in Saudi
Arabia uh the Riyadh invited China while
it also has a great relationship with
the United States so yes a lot of
mid-sized countries are finding it
easier now not to be dealing vertically
with one superpower or another but
dealing with more than one power that's
making things easier for these countries
but it's also making it easier in terms
of betting and hedging right because
let's say you decide to give up on
Russia completely several relations and
said with the United States what
guarantees are there that in 2025
there won't be a president de santis or
president Trump that will simply forget
about these countries like President
Trump did when he entered office so it
is an ambiguous it is unreliable world
and everyone is looking for their own
interest and no one is looking really
for the common good indeed we might say
it's a movable political Feast for the
moment Marvin thanks very much for your
Insight thank you